Oh
so you hear people complain these days
that everything is becoming automated
the robots are stealing our jobs
ai is coming The Terminator scenario you
know but I think that ultimately people
don't really have a reason to be scared
because I think that what artificial
intelligence ultimately comes down to
what outsourcing our cognition into the
machines is really all about it's about
amplifying the most powerful phenomenon
in the universe which is intelligence
we're finally learning through reverse
engineered to still understand reproduce
intelligence once we can create
sentience that is not bound by the
bandwidth of our physicality of our
biology will literally be creating a
sentence that can upgrade itself minds
that create minds computers that build
better computers and at this point the
runaway train that literally is speeding
up at an exponential rate will leave
everything behind the human era will
have ended we will have become our
creations they will be our children but
they will really be us there is no
reason to fear this this is just
evolution
you